Okay. So I alluded to this before. Cookies are sent
in HTTP headers. So when a server and, and an HTTP
response, wants to give you a cookie, wants to assign a
cookie to your browser it uses a header that looks something
like this. The header name is Set-Cookie. Like all headers, it's
followed by a colon and then a space and then the
value of the header. And in this particular case, you say,
name equals value. There are some other parameters you can have
on the cookie that we'll discuss later but, basically, they use
the Set-Cookie header to, to set cookie named user_id to this
value. And remember, this is the value, and this is the
name, and the value can be, you know, up to 4K.
Honestly, I don't know if there's a limit to how big
the name can be. generally, this is very, very short. If
the server wants to set, send the multiple cookies, it can
do so by using multiple Set-Cookie, Cookie headers. There's no restriction
that says headers have to be unique. A, a server can
send as many cookies as it wants. It's up to the browser
to decide whether or not to store them. Remember, I said about
20 is the max. So try to, try to keep it under
there. Now, when, when a, this is under Response. Now, in
future requests, the browser sends its own header, that this is the,
the name of the header, and remember, this is, you know, this
is also the name of the header, over here, Set-Cookie and then
the value of the header, in this case, is user_id
equals 12345. Again, we have the, the name of the
cookie and the value of the cookie. If we were
to make this H, this request match what these two cookies
were to, when our browser sends multiple cookies, it'll look
something like this, user_id equals 12345; which separates each cookie from
each other, and then any other cookies. So the browser
sends one cookie header with all of your cookies in it.
The semicolon is important and you may be wondering, well, what
if I want to put a semicolon in my cookie value? And the
short answer is, don't. And if you really want to, encode
the cookie value, you know? You, this, this can be whatever you
want. The browser doesn't care so you can, you can Base64
it, you can encrypt it, you can ROT13 it, you can do
whatever you want here but make sure you escape those semicolons
so you don't goof up your the incoming cookie header. Some frameworks
will do this for you. We are going to be operating
at a lower level so that's something you'll want to think about.